it's just interesting looking at the
philosophical tradition of this
difficult ideas you struggle with if you
look like somebody
like
emmanuel kant what are some interesting
agreements and disagreements you
have uh with a guy about the nature of
reality
so there's a lot in agreement right so
kant was an idealist
transcendental ideas and
he he basically had the idea that um
we don't see nature as it is we impose
the structure on nature
he
and and so in some sense i'm saying
something similar i'm saying that by the
way i don't call myself an idealist i
call myself a conscious realist because
idealism has a long history a lot of
different
ideas come under idealism and there's a
lot of debates and so forth it this
tends to be identified with in many
cases anti-science and anti-realism
and i don't want either connection with
my ideas and so i just called mine
conscious realism with an emphasis on
realism
and not and not anti-realism
but but the one place where i would of
course disagree with kant was that he
thought that um
euclidean
space time was a priori
right we just know that that's that's
false
so so he he went to too far
on that but
but in in general the idea that we don't
start with space time that space and
time is in some sense forms of our
perceptions yes absolutely
and
i would say that you know
there's a lot in common with barclay in
that regard
there's a lot of ingenious arguments in
barclay
leibniz
leibniz in this monadology
understood very clearly that the hard
problem was not solvable
he posed the hard problem and basically
dismissed it just you can't do this
and so if he came here he
and saw where we are he said look guys i
told you this 300 years ago and he had
his momentology he was trying
to do something like this it's
um
it's different from what i'm doing but
he he had these things that were not in
space and time the these moan ads he was
trying to build something
um
i'm trying to build a theory of
conscious agents my guess is that if
he came here i could just
if he saw what i was doing he would say
he would understand it and immediately
take off with it and go places that i
couldn't he he would he would so there
would be uh right there would be overlap
of uh the spirit of the ideas absolutely
totally overlapping but his genius would
then just run with it far faster than i
could
you